I would like to think of it as a social programmer.
I think society is going to be a lot more technological.
We're going to have augmented reality interfaces.
We're going to have interfaces to government,
to civic institutions,
and I think programmers aren't going to be sitting
in front of screens so much
as walking in and around people
and adjusting that interface on the fly
to suit, sort of,
as it happens,
interfaces that people need at events,
government.
And I like the idea of a programmer
who talks to people
and then makes those interfaces
sort of become instantiated.
That would be a cool job.
That would be a job I'd want.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.